hey guys i'm dia betty hi i'm june
jambalaya i'm bosco hey you guys it's me
deja skye hey everybody it's me jasmine
kennedy i'm carrie colby how are y'all
doing hi everybody it's georges hi it's
orion's story hello it's willow pill
cornbread the mother snack jete so i'm
melissa hunter i'm andrea paris van
michaels but you can call me angie hi
i'm maddie morphisus and my name is lady
camden and we are the cast of rupaul's
drag race season 14 here with buzzfeed
to play a game of who's who
who's most likely to become a viral meme
of the season
yeah
viral meme for sure for sure it doesn't
she is just so like ditzy and she'll
just say whatever comes out of her mouth
well i can totally see her just saying
something random yeah definitely
definitely i'll say that or two for me
i'll say
angie for
sure nigeria paris van life
probably maddie it it's gonna be angie
there's some there's so much mean
potential of what you can make something
out of and angie she's gonna be giving
you faces she's gonna be giving you
moments she's gonna be giving you sound
bites like there is so much mean
potential that's gonna happen with angie
like it's it's just gonna be a thing uh
mine is definitely cornbread mine is
definitely cornbread because cornbread
is always doing or saying something
stupid i would have to say jasmine
because she's ridiculous
i pick cornbread because this is going
to be making like all the damn faces
like that y'all like everything because
she's going to be giving you like you
know
and she'd be going like this too so
she's going to she's going to be giving
you all the memes and all the titty
shaking jasmine
100
no doubt in my mind i'm gonna say
jasmine because she is a lot that girl
can talk maybe it's the new yorker and
her i don't know she has a lot to say i
think jasmine was created in a
laboratory to be on television she is
absolutely going to be the viral meme of
the season i think nigeria because
ngeria is really funny and her accent
and she's so sweet who's most likely to
have an iconic catchphrase from the
season george's me
i said me
i say some stupid that yeah that people
just have to make a thing up so that's
true i i use some of the things you said
on the season in my day-to-day lives you
might be right
i said georges not because of the
ridiculous stuff she says but she says
it repeatedly and so it's like
repetition helps get it in your mind
like george's is going to have some
catchphrases that i said um kerry colby
because i just think that she's
hysterical and she just has a lot of
really funny things that she says that
crack me up so i'm i'm looking out for
those valen the crit
i said i said i said george's because
you're just outside he said she repeat a
lot since that meet the queen's like oh
my god oh my god oh my god i'm charging
so she's kind of like that sweetness but
baby
sometimes you have a chicken mine no
shape but i love georges that's my
latina amazing sister angelia cornbread
i'd agree i definitely say cornbread
cornbread does not care what she says
out of her mouth and
she and it's she's genuinely does not
care so
but there's always a sense of love yeah
oh no there's so much
but it's like always funny perfect her
timing is impeccable i think it's going
to be angeria for the same reasons why
june said that she'll probably be like
the most viral memeable person she just
is a catchphrase machine so funny
without trying to be like she can try to
be funny and also be funny but like
she's just naturally so enjoyable to be
around and watch me courtroom cornbread
definitely be cornbread she's so witty
and like she throws out those one-liners
that you're just like jesus christ
sister definitely cornbread i
definitely think that i paid attention
to some things that can pop off and
people will be into repeating but we'll
have to see
[Music]
congress
i said deja she's a crazy
dumb and i live for it and she's wild
she's rowdy and i love it i picked
cornbread because she's got a little
catchphrase for everything that you know
bands are ready to go one two three
who's most likely to deliver a savage
rita at any given moment moscow that is
something i've learned about bosco
especially as we've become even closer
after filming his wrapped she might be
quiet a lot of the times but she's
always thinking point of view on what's
happening just not always saying it but
when she does say it it's hilarious
i'm going to say bosco because she's my
gemini sister so i get the shade and i
get where it's coming from and where i
may
not say it oh she
um my love language is [ __ ] talking so
and i love these girls a lot so i talk a
lot
oh jewish
i said bosco
as well
is so quick on her feet like oh my god
like she is so quick like bostok can
read like all four of us at one time
convert have the ability and the talent
baby to read every single one of you
even though rupaul's i said cornbread as
well because like it's the quickness of
it like you'll get red and you won't
even realize it happened to you it'll
give you whiplash have it so quick um i
actually said many morphouses because i
remember a few things that she said that
cracked me up that came as a surprise so
i would go ahead and be ready
the reason why i said bosco was because
funny like it's quick and she's smart
which is funny because a lot of the
times i feel like she's she can be kind
of like to herself like she's kind of
quiet but then when she does talk it's
like boom who's most likely to help a
fellow queen get ready for the runway
you cornbread what sabotage
i said deja she's like the mother figure
for all of us you know she's like you
know always checking on everybody she's
always like trying to lend a helping
hand i said derisha too because she's
kind of like atheia in a way like
yeah yeah she's a thea if you don't know
what it means i mean it's like an auntie
you know
she's like very bad she's very like
nurturing sometimes she like likes to
like rock me like
in her arms and i live for that it's
definitely and she's a really good
seamstress as well deja actually made a
lot of my stuff before i went to the
show so dave's very good for the runway
i still say me because delusion is best
served with a side of cornbread but
definitely deja vu deja vu
i literally was the mother of the group
so if anyone needed help i was there to
help you girl as long as you didn't cut
into my time i was there to help you
mama i think uh cornbread also she gives
so much energy to everyone and she's
always the one to make sure that if
you're feeling down she'll make sure to
be like look around you and see where
you're at you're on drag race so make
sure you get out of that funk she was
definitely the auntie for sure
yeah and i said jasmine because jasmine
is going to be ready before all the rest
of us yeah
we're still going to be putting on
eyelashes and jasmine is going to be
like already fully dressed so she got
time to help us i said cornbread again
because cornbread she'll not only make
sure you're ready for the runway to help
you zip up she'll make sure you're
hydrated you have something to eat
you're mentally proud like she's gonna
make sure you are prepared i said deja
skye because that's my california sister
i love her and uh yeah i think she's
just a big old love bug that one sorry i
said there's just guys yeah angie
because angie helped me in one of my
challenges you know because we are legal
together they helped me to skip
something and yeah i say june because i
feel like june always she's always there
to like not only just help you get ready
for the runway but like if you have
something on your mind you want to talk
it out like she is there just to listen
if you want advice from her she's she's
just very very sweet and very helpful
even outside of the race so love my girl
i did say deja though just because deja
personally helped me with like a lot of
my runway needs at our time there but
june is also always there for like
emotional support if you need to borrow
some shoes if you need some advice if
you need some hair june is incredibly
giving as well i'm going to say deja
some of the challenges that i struggled
with um she was there and you know very
supportive and helpful who is most
likely to borrow a piece of clothing
from one of the other queens and never
return it i die
completely
okay here's the thing i borrowed wins
but i always return the win
always returns because it would die i
gave her a thing and i haven't got it
back
mother says she could keep them
she could keep up i don't care i don't i
would never wear a gun but still i won't
explain what type of shoes they are but
they're a pair of shoes they're not
expensive um
no her foot's bigger but she fitted in
orion
i think orion would definitely be like
oh hey i'm missing this piece can i
borrow this from you but i think she'd
just be so high that she would forget
that she borrowed it she wouldn't
intentionally steal it
it's not that she'll do it intentionally
but i think she's so ditzy like she just
forgets that she even has it like girl
just be sitting in her station like can
i have my stuff back please we all we
all kind of like took something from set
like little things right i took a brush
you know
yeah
i still got it yeah but she took a
sewing machine so she's obviously the
pro at taking time
this is going to be used in her
deposition by the way oh
girl i'm sorry but that i know that i
don't want to get in trouble but that
blew my mind i was like how did you
guess girl now they're going to be
asking for they saw a machine like oh
diabetes stuff uh looks like compiled
with so much stuff if you let her borrow
something i'm pretty sure you'll never
find it diet has a lot of pieces and a
lot of puzzles that go to her stuff so
yeah you never get it's like it's like
losing a sock in the dryer you're never
getting that sock back me
did i just out myself
i don't know if i ever caught her
stealing but i bet she would yeah i'm
gonna say willow is stinky you gotta be
careful
i i just said myself because um there
were multiple instances where i had to
borrow some things from miss bosco over
here
yeah i had a few costume pieces that are
on like loan throughout the season i did
get them all back though so she didn't
keep them who's most likely to say
something shady during a confessional
that shady yeah you know bosco is
actually true too i said myself and what
happened in those rooms probably me in
boston me and bosco we've talked about
it i think we're done
in the season
kennedy
me or bob go it's definitely your boss
stuff everything i say in my
confessional people's faces myself you
know what i appreciate it yeah
i would say boscar jasmine for sure yeah
yeah definitely jasmine was always nice
to me so i have no idea
but that's the thing is jasmine is sweet
she's so sweet but get her in the right
mood
thanks right give me at least an eight
listen i just know how you work she like
i said she doesn't always say things
when we're in big groups but i know when
it's just one-on-one she's got some
words yeah she's gonna give it to you
would consider myself pretty high up on
that list but i do think willow is
secretly the biggest bit head on cast
and i mean that with as much love as
possible bosco boss cornbread like boska
would say it to your face but it she
would also absolutely she would say the
funniest shadiest stuff in the
confessionals
first yeah i said cornbread like even
though she's very real i think she threw
a lot of shake too in her own style but
baby you need to be careful with that
like girl baby yeah baby like like to
shave but he's still shave baby he's
still shaking who
is most likely to be distracted by the
pit crew
you have to understand
this man
is so
massive and
huge
i would go say alyssa probably was
interested in the cast deja was
interested in the crew
i was with someone that i couldn't get
you know what i don't know okay
deja is always horny always talking
about sex she always has something to
say about she's she's probably taking
her computer and her history to the
grave because the first thing alyssa
asked somebody is not so tell me about
yourself she goes are you a top a bottom
a verse yeah
that's the first thing alyssa will say
to you the first thing so ellis because
the list of a [ __ ]
me me me me me and i believe you maybe
that'll be crew
i said deja like whenever the pit crew
came in the room like she had those
hungry eyes she wasn't even looking at
the chocolate either she was just
looking at the pit crew because she was
always running around there talking
about ooh slay me fierce daddy and i was
like just boy crazy i said myself as
well because i actually did get quite
distracted several times where i would
like forget that i was gonna just be
like georges georges
i was gonna say alyssa yeah but george's
is just blatantly obvious when she's
feeling it yeah she was in heat the
entire visa thank you so much for
checking out buzzfeed thank you so much
buzzfeed thank you so much for having us
buzzfeed thank you so much buzzfeed you
can catch rupaul's drag race season 14
on vh1
[Music]